so back then we were collecting they
were doing the crimes
they got sent to jail because you could
only convict the guy who did the crime
even though i [ __ ] sent the guy to go
see a guy in a different way
deceive it in the [ __ ] different way
yeah yeah you know that's how we benefit
it's funny too and also in the fierce
city uh documentary i remember um john
i was talking about something about how
when rico when it came on the news
and then they they saw that like you
know this guy was convicted that guy was
convicted or castellano got convicted
he's like you know we were [ __ ]
trying to figure it out like we're a
couple of harvard graduates over here
you remember when he said that yeah he's
like everybody all of a sudden he said
all these [ __ ] all these wise guys
they went to harvard all of a sudden
yeah and they're telling me about this
or that
i was like that was funny too yeah i
mean you could just picture him going
like he talking to smugglers
you know yeah i know you went to harvard
and all that you went to harvard but
i mean let's be honest if you like
sucking dicks too right yeah that's what
i mean that comes with the [ __ ]
package of picking up a buck what is the
podcast can we get john a light's
podcast and promote it a little bit here
if i see why not we're gonna have to do
something we gotta do something
you know what let's [ __ ] whatever his
podcast name is let's reach out to him
and say you should change the name of
the podcast to
come see me in a different way oh john
eli and jean barello this is the guy
gene barrello if you look at the vlad tv
go vlad tv uh put in john a light jean
barrel the
the podcast both these guys were on and
i guess we're doing a podcast together i
bet you the podcast is fascinating
the johnny and jean show because can we
listen can we can we hear it can we just
at least hear it we don't get to see
a couple of minutes of it or i just want
to see can we not yeah i mean
how funny if he turned it on he was
talking about uh if he was talking about
dining room feng shui
yeah i mean he's like hey what's up this
is john elliott uh welcome back to the
name of the podcast
studios concrete podcast i mean the kid
is still jacked he will hurt you
okay wait a second he'll [ __ ] crush
this kid
who's this [ __ ] democrat what the
[ __ ] is going on here
we gotta get on this guy's podcast i
know
this guy this guy will [ __ ] hurt you
he'll hurt you bad yeah
major yeah i mean these guys always talk
about truckloads
because in a day a day in the life of a
guy who was a soldier
for the mafia at some point during the
day he's taught he's going to say the
word truckload
truckload do you think guys in the mafia
ever just have to dip it to a rite aid
to get some clarity and take their blood
pressure
do you think these guys ever were like
you know what i know we got a job we got
to cut this guy up but my
my i'm sneezing my sciences are crazy
right now so can we just stop and get a
little clarity congestion and
maybe if just no decongesting because
the deacon just erased my blood pressure
that was a funny thing when they when
you know i was listening to this other
documentary where they said
they would they would tap the social
club of john gotti
and others before whatever and he said
you think mobster's conversations are
real interesting
but a lot of the time it's it's so it's
even more boring
because they know it or suspect they're
being tapped so the guys would talk
about spaghetti endlessly
the mafia started in the 1920s that's
why it really kicked off
that's what really kicked off the united
states i mean it was going on in sicily
for a while
and i think it's still relatively
prevalent in sicily i think just in the
united states
you don't really get [ __ ] with rico
can you go up a little bit you're kind
of like yeah they're just kind of like
imitation greeks
right they're kind of like not the real
deal you know what i mean like they just
we we like we we should have
we shouldn't have did what we did which
was create logic and reason mathematics
because the italians just took all that
and just started robbing
they just know a way to just kind of
catch a break i i know there was a um
i forgot what it was but now a lot of
people have done it there was a
restaurant i think in little italy
that there was like a squid shortage
with calamari fresh calamari
um which is a [ __ ] tragedy in the
entire tragedy yeah
calamari there was a [ __ ] you're
doing the great calamari shortage of 96
yeah the column
were you when they ran out of water that
one of the mafia foot soldiers found out
away because the price was going up in
in
in squid for whatever reason that he
just was like he [ __ ] started putting
pig anus
and making it look like calamari and
throat drawing the rumor no that's real
throwing that in red sauce and then that
so now
a lot of times when you go to like a not
classy italian place they'll have
[ __ ]
column imitation calamari's pig [ __ ]
and some mafia foot soldiers guy that
found out how to do that
that's an example of an italian guy
that's an italian guy
he's got a good sense of humor now it's
a nice example of italian guy getting
screwed in
and making calamari in a different way
in a different way yeah
and then you have a very smart
businessman there was um the man michael
franchezi who's also in fear city
documented also did a vlad tv interview
very very famous guy he was like the
businessman of this all i believe is
michael francesi
was making something like five million
dollars a month doing just
business deals and you watch him and
you're like you and you listen to me and
you're like this guy is so
beyond intelligent but he'll also come
at you in a different way
if if you know yeah here it is fierce
city is one
i personally thought it's one of the
best things netflix has put out in all
of quarantine
it was it's great and if you like france
boil down
the sicilian mafia into one sentence
it's basically that
they say hey we're here to do business
we are going to do it this way
and if you don't abide by what we want
and how we want to do it
we will see you in a different way i
think anything in real estate
waste management the docs in new york or
new jersey it's all still to this day
somehow mafia owned somewhere donald
trump
is maf it's mafia money that's right he
didn't get those buildings
from his dad that's mafia stuff that put
those buildings up
there was an era where if you were doing
any building in new york you had to deal
with concrete companies
right and unions and work and yeah they
were all in that
um and then the mafia got broken up the
the star of the show who really
broke up the mafia who had their
tentacles in all these legitimate
businesses
they were extorting everybody like you
said like with the trash guy what he's
doing
is he's eliminating the competition what
they basically the mafia
is like that is what the mafia is is
we'll come see in a different way do
business with us
give us money you can't really boil down
the mafia better than that sentence
we're going to name it
we'll come soon in a different way in a
different way that's the name of it so
and that's
gonna make that a t-shirt too we're
gonna come shoot it differently in a
[ __ ] different way and then you go
guess who's gonna come see us in a
different way for using his saying
and making money yeah we really hope you
enjoyed that episode whatever it was
about this is just a stock thing that
we're taping on to every episode
so go make sure you rate review
us subscribe uh turn on your
notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild
[Music]
huh